wir hatten heute eine intensive und nach
meiner überzeugung auch sehr wichtige
debatte denn wir stehen wieder einmal an
einer neuen stelle oder einer neuen an
der schwelle einer neuen phase der
pandemie eine phase in die wir eben
nicht mit sorglosigkeit aber doch und
das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig zu sagen
mit berechtigten hoffnungen hineingehen
können wir können heute von hoffnung und
dem übergang übergang in eine neue phase
sprechen weil wir ja alle in den letzten
monaten in unserem land sehr viel
erreicht haben als das virus sich im
herbst dramatisch ausgebreitet hatte
haben wir uns alle zusammen dem entgegen
gestellt und das ist verbunden gewesen
mit schweren für manchen auch
ungeheuerlich belastenden
einschränkungen mit zeitweiligen
eingriffen in unsere freiheit in unsere
wirtschaftsordnung wird unser
kulturelles leben und zwar in einer
weise wie es sie noch nie gab in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland
was wir gemeinsam durchgestanden haben
das war hart aber man kann heute auch
sagen es hat wirkung gezeigt es war
wirksam und das hat erfolge gebracht auf
die wir gemeinsam auch stolz sein können
und ich möchte den bürgerinnen und
bürgern dafür auch noch einmal danken
wir haben unsere intensivstationen von
einer gefährlichen notlage um die
weihnachtszeit herum und vom rand der
belastung und überlastung zurückgeholt
wir haben es geschafft die ausbreitung
des virus einzudämmen
und auch jetzt wo wir schon die
ansteckenden mutationen des virus bei
uns immer weiter vordringen sehen haben
wir neue tägliche infektionszahlen die
im europäischen vergleich zu den
niedrigeren gehören
und bei alledem haben wir es mit einer
großen kraftanstrengung des staates
geschafft einen ost neue
massenarbeitslosigkeit zu verhindern
haben riesige summen mobilisiert um
unsere wirtschaft durch diese extreme
zeit zu bringen und bei allem was
unvollkommen ist und da gibt es manches
hat deutschland stärke gezeigt in seiner
reaktion auf die zweite welle der
pandemie und jetzt liegt die aufgabe der
politik und darüber haben wir heute so
viele stunden gesprochen darin die
nächsten schritte klug zu gehen
es sollen schritte der eröffnung sein
und gleichzeitig schritte die uns in der
pandemie nicht zurückwerfen dürfen
in europa gibt es sehr viele beispiele
einer dramatischen dritten welle und
diese gefahr da dürfen wir uns nichts
vormachen besteht auch für uns und
dessen müssen wir uns immer bewusst sein
trotzdem kann ich heute sagen der
frühling 2021 wird anders sein als der
frühling vor einem jahr
wir sind heute in vieler hinsicht weiter
und das liegt in erster linie an zwei
helfern die wir haben gegen das virus
und die wir 2020 einfach noch nicht
hatten und diese beiden helfer sind die
impfstoffe die verschiedenen impfstoffe
und die ganze bandbreite von tests die
erweiterten testmöglichkeiten haben wir
heute zuerst besprochen genauso wie das
impfen und diese erweiterten
testmöglichkeiten erlauben es uns das
infektionsgeschehen besser zu
kontrollieren und öffnungs schritte auch
abzusichern und das impfen ist der weg
hinaus aus der pandemie das ist der
zuverlässigste helfer der weg um das
virus tatsächlich wirklich zu überwinden
und deshalb haben diese beiden
instrumente der pandemie bekämpfung in
unseren beratungen heute breiten raum
eingenommen sie haben auch am beginn
unserer beratungen gestanden
zuerst zum impfen die meisten der
gefährdeten also die hochbetagten in den
einrichtungen und wie menschen die sich
medizinisch und pflegerisch um sie
kümmern sind inzwischen geimpft das ein
echtes mehr an sicherheit
und gott sei dank zeigt sich dass auch
langsam in der sinkenden zahl von
todesfällen oder wenn es noch ausbrüche
von corona in pflegeheimen gibt in den
leichteren verlauf
fachleute erwarten dass wir auch bald
noch deutlich
gesehen werden und wir haben heute lange
darüber gesprochen wie wir das impfen
deutlich forcieren können und wie wir es
so auch organisieren können dass die
zahl der möglichen erstimpfung maximal
ausgeschöpft wird wir wollen alle
flexibilität nutzen und wir wissen dass
wir hier auch in einem wettlauf gegen
die zeit sind und deshalb haben wir
folgendes heute vereinbart erstens der
abstand zwischen den der erste und der
zweite impfung bei den jeweiligen
impfstoffen also bei biotech und bei
astrazeneca soll maximal ausgenutzt
werden das heißt immer erst zum ende der
genehmigungsphase piontek 42 tage
astrazeneca zwölf wochen soll die zweite
impfung verabreicht werden dadurch
können wir schneller mehr menschen
menschen erst impfen
das wird auch von der ständigen
impfkommission empfohlen zweitens wird
es wohl so sein dass die ständige
impfkommission und dem folgen wir gerne
astrazeneca auch für höhere
altersgruppen zu lassen wird die
neuesten studien haben dafür ja evidenz
ergeben
drittens geht es darum bei
möglicherweise nicht wahrgenommene ins
terminen auch ein kluges nachrücker
management zu entwickeln
und hier sollte flexibilität auch
angewandt werden und das wird durch die
zukünftigen im verordnung durch den
gesundheitsminister auch gesichert
werden
hausärzte können heute schon über die
länder mit in die impf arbeit mit
einbezogen werden das wird auch noch mal
festgelegt in der umformung die anfang
nächster woche in kraft tritt viertens
die arbeit in den impfzentren dass es
von den bundesländern noch einmal
bestätigt worden
kann jederzeit auf ein meer schicht
system umgestellt werden und auch sieben
tage ausgedehnt werden dass es überhaupt
keine frage
und fünftens ende märz anfang april soll
als zweiter strang neben den impfzentren
die belieferung der hausärzte etabliert
werden damit noch mehr flexibilität in
die gesamte geschichte kommt das heißt
also so schnell wie möglich impfstoffe
an die menschen bringen und wir glauben
wir hier noch steigerungspotenzial haben
der zweite held das ist das testen
schnelltest und dann auch die
selbsttests sagen mit guter genauigkeit
ob jemand tagesaktuell ansteckend ist
und für diesen tag können solche tests
dann auch mehr sicherheit für kontakte
geben und man kann vor allen dingen auch
asymptomatische erkrankte sehr gut
herausfiltern und david ansteckungskette
unterbinden wo man das sonst gar nicht
sehen würde und diese systematischen
tests wollen wir neben den heute schon
bestehenden antigen schnelltests
natürlich dann auch umfassend nutzen
dazu gibt es drei säulen die eine säule
ist die der bundesgesundheitsminister
bereits angeboten hatte und jetzt ab dem
8 märz zur verfügung stehen soll nämlich
ein von der vom bund erstattet
kostenloser test für jeden bürger und
für jede bürgerin pro woche das heißt
dieses angebot gilt ab dem 8 märz und
die entsprechenden testzentren werden
vor ort dafür zur verfügung gestellt
zweitens testungen in schule und kita
das ist ja ein anliegen dass wir durch
die bundesländer auch immer wieder
deutlich gemacht wurde
es geht jetzt hier darum dass zum teil
heute schon mit den herkömmlichen
antigen schnelltest getestet wird die
sind auch in ausreichender menge
vorhanden aber durch die technologische
neuerungen werden die selbsttests sehr
viel einfacher anzuwenden seien
und wenn es um die beschaffung dieser
test auch für die länder für die schulen
und kitas geht werden wir eine
gemeinsame task force gründen bund und
länder und plattformanbieter damit
beauftragen
gesammelte bestellungen und angebote
auch durchzuführen das heißt also eine
dienstleistung die durch private
plattformanbieter geleistet werden kann
und vom bund und länder eng
zusammenarbeiten werden und die dritte
säule ist die zurverfügungstellung der
arbeit für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer von antigenen schnelltests
sowohl herkömmliche art als auch neue
art je nachdem wie das an
boot ist durch die wirtschaft dazu
werden wir die gespräche als
bundesregierung fortsetzen am freitag
wir haben hier also ausführlich
gesprochen das sind die helfer die
unsere öffnungs maßnahmen begleiten und
wir haben uns dann sehr intensiv die man
sich vorstellen kann mit den nächsten
öffnungs schritten befasst und hier fünf
weitere oder fünf schritte vereinbart
da ist der erste jahr seit dem ersten
drittel bereits dass schulen und auch
schon etwas vorher vor dem ersten
drittel und friseure und gewisse
regionale öffnung seit dem anfang märz
zur verfügung stehen oder schon in kraft
getreten sind
der zweite öffnungs schritt ist dann
jetzt ab dem 8 und hier haben wir
jeweils bei jedem öffnungs schritt das
gleiche muster angewandt ob erster
zweiter dritter vierter oder fünfter
öffnungs schritt ab dem zweiten öffnungs
schritt das gleiche muster nämlich dass
wir sagen wir brauchen eine stabile oder
sinkende tendenz und einsetzen tun die
öffnungs schritte entweder bei instanzen
runter 50 dann gibt es erleichterte
bedingungen
ich sag gleich was dazu oder bei
instanzen über 50 dann sind restriktive
maßnahmen in den verschiedenen strängen
die schon oft genannt habe von kontakt
beschränkungen von schulen möglichkeiten
von fragen der kultur des handels der
gastronomie und ähnliches werden zu
bestimmten paketen geschnürt
ein nächster eröffnungs schritt kann
immer dann erfolgen wenn eine stabile
oder sinkenden tendenz nach 14 tagen des
vorherigen öffnungs schrittes da ist das
heißt immer eröffnungs schritt 2 und
sehe dann nach 14 tagen was hat meine
inzidenz erbracht ist sie stabil oder
sinkt sie sogar
da kann ich die nächsten öffnungs
schritt gehen und wenn auf dem weg
zwischen einem eröffnungs schritt und
dem nächsten die incidents von 100
also die verdoppelung von 50 passiert
dann muss ich wenn das drei
aufeinanderfolgende tage so ist an dem
zwei darauf folgenden tag dann den
schritt wieder zurückgehen zum
ausgangspunkt so wie es vor dem r8 märz
war das heißt wir bauen eine notbremse 1
wenn wir in ein exponentielles wachstum
geraten deshalb die 100 die verdoppelung
der 50 dann muss sozusagen wieder
zurückgegangen werden zu der situation
vor dem 8 märz das heißt wir arbeiten in
einem raum der natürlich wenn man jetzt
mal den rk ii empfehlungen sich anschaut
dann ist größer 50 immer schon eine sehr
gefährliche zone
wir wissen dass bei 50 die kontakt
nachverfolgung sehr viel schwieriger
wird aber wir geben politisch sozusagen
einen spielraum einen puffer weil wir
auf die neuen testmöglichkeiten
vertrauen und weil wir sagen wir haben
hier mehr überblick bei unseren weiteren
öffnungs schritten und gehen dann diese
öffnung schritte schritt für schritt ab
dem 8 dann also einzelhandel bei unter
50 kann er geöffnet werden incidents bei
über 50 click and meet bei über 50
können museen galerien und zoos und
botanische gärten geöffnet werden wenn
man eine termin buchung hat eine
dokumentation vorgenommen wird der
besucher und es gibt bestimmte außen
sportmöglichkeiten für wenige personen
bei wenn das 50 und bei unter 50 kann
der einzelhandel aufmachen mit
quadratmeter beschränkungen museen
galerien source botanische gärten auch
außen sport auch aber etwas im
erweiterten mit masse haben wir 14 tage
eine stabile incidents oder sinkende
dann können wir den nächsten öffnungs
schritt also frühestens am 22 märz gehen
der würde dann umfassen die
außengastronomie mit vorheriger
terminbuch und wenn man über 50 liegt
bei unter 50 die außengastronomie
ganz allgemein er würde umfassen
theater- konzert- und opernhäuser und
kinos dabei jeweils mit einer
absicherung durch einen schnelltest und
unter 50 wieder ohne dass es notwendig
ist dass tests vorgezeigt werden und
dann auch wieder bestimmte sportliche
möglichkeiten
wir haben dann einen weiteren öffnung
schritt ins auge gefasst der kann
frühestens 14 tage später also am
fünften april stattfinden und da geht es
dann um die öffnung des einzelhandels
wenn die inzidenz stabil bleibt und um
weitere sportmöglichkeiten und wenn es
eine inzidenz unter 50 ist können sogar
freizeitveranstaltungen im außenbereich
mit maximal 50 teilnehmern möglich sein
so haben wir also ein gestuftes konzept
am 22.04 werden wir dann darüber
sprechen wie es mit den anderen
bereichen zum beispiel hotels
ferienwohnungen und andere weitergeht
wichtig also notbremse
die auch wirklich akkurat eingehalten
werden muss drei aufeinanderfolgende
tage über 100 dann am übernächsten tag
zurück zudem zu den maßnahmen die wir
vor dem 83 hatten das ganze ist glaube
ich jetzt ein konzept der
verlässlichkeit es ist ein konzept des
schrittweisen vorgehens das war mir auch
sehr wichtig dass wir hier pakete
schnüren die nicht sozusagen zu groß
sind und dennoch wissen wir dass
angesichts der auf wachsenden mutation
wir sind jetzt bei etwa 50 prozent
wir werden in den nächsten tagen
natürlich dann erleben dass die
britische mutation die dominante
mutation wird und die ursprünglich das
ursprüngliche virus verschwindet und
deshalb befinden wir uns in einer sehr
heiklen phase
und deshalb wird es auch darauf ankommen
dass alle anderen kontakt beschränkungen
und alle anderen aha regeln und alles
was wir uns angewöhnt haben in der
pandemie akkurat 1
und auch tests erworben nicht dass man
sozusagen die abstandsregeln und anderes
nicht mehr ein
wir verlängern des roboters bis zum 30
und wir werden daran arbeiten eine
kontakt nachverfolgung insbesondere für
besucher von veranstaltungen von
außengastronomie und ähnlichem in die
elektrik elektronischer form zu
installieren die bundeseinheitlich von
ländern ausgewählt wird sie kennen als
beispiel das system luca die länder
wehren sich für ein solches system
kurzfristig entscheiden
und das ganze wird dann auch mit den
gesundheitsämtern verbunden so dass wir
eine elektronische kontakt
nachverfolgung bundeseinheitlich in der
länderkompetenz dann auch durchsetzen
können wir werden ein härtefallfonds
einrichten für die wirtschaftshilfen
dazu werden die details noch sehr
zeitnah geklärt aber sie werden die
kosten dafür werden hälftig von bund und
ländern übernommen
der kinderbonus den wir schon vereinbart
hatten in der koalition wird von dem
bund finanziell übernommen und wir
werden bei einer weiteren mpk auch noch
mal über erweiterte kinder krankentage
sprechen wenn die stadt daun maßnahmen
noch weiter gelten müssen ich glaube es
waren harte verhandlungen
es ist eine phase die bis mit viel
hoffnung verbunden ich weiß für viel wie
viele menschen diese hoffnungen auch
sind wir werden sicherlich auch
hoffnungen enttäuschen aber wir sind der
meinung gewesen dass wir mehr hoffnungen
enttäuschen wenn wir zu oft hin und her
müssen und zurück müssen und deshalb
wollen wir die wollen wir diese
möglichkeiten nutzen wir haben noch eine
vereinbarung getroffen bei kommunen die
unter 35 liegen oder regionen
bundesländer sind es zurzeit nicht
können noch einmal erweiterte
kontaktmöglichkeiten gegeben werden also
nicht nur zwei haushalte und fünf
personen wobei die kinder nicht zählen
sondern ein haushalt mit plus zwei
weitere also im grunde drei haushalte es
soll sich also auch lohnen sich
anzustrengen vor ort wirklich
infektionen nicht weiterzugeben und wir
hoffen darauf dass wir durch diese
regionalisierung und auch die länder
bezogenheit mit der wir jetzt arbeiten
also mehr vielfalt haben dass wir
dadurch auch anreize schaffen dass jeder
sich noch mehr anstrengen dass wir
möglichst viel normales leben wieder
zurückgewinnen können denn das ist ja
unser ziel